five years after a second civil war
broke out in Ivory Coast and violence
raged for months
many former militiamen are unemployed
some 65,000 fought in all and since
being demobilized some 10,000 have still
not received any help from the state
musa Fofana is one of them after giving
up his arms he was out of a job for
years now he's found an apprenticeship
position but will he be able to lead a
normal life
Mousa Fofana hasn't lost any of his
strengths and he's used to putting
effort into his work he was marked by
his time as a militiamen his life during
the months of civil war in 2011 was
intensive and dangerous for my son
that's what we were told when we were
training if you do this you'll build up
the strength in your arms then you'll be
able to shoot straighter if you're
strong the shots are less likely to miss
it's County dissident on you can talk
further about it is a big deal for half
a year the 29 year old has been doing an
apprenticeship as a car body maker in
devdi Baggett is repair shop I'm gonna
hurt you you know my money your chicken
now if you get moose on knows how to
give orders that's what he was trained
to do so new boss it's not up to you to
tell him what to do that's just how it
is
agua
everything here reminds him of the Civil
War
ex-president LaJuan Gbagbo's snipers
took up position in the unfinished
buildings up as at the repair shop he
can't forget the time when former
president Gbagbo's militias went out on
the rampage hunting down anyone who
didn't support them including mooses
family who were killed I saw them from a
distance at my home so I thought they
were looking for me what could I do
I ran off so I came back in the evening
I don't know what happened I went back
two hours later all dead my parents two
little brothers my little sister
the DPT fire please admit it sir
that's when he decided to join forces
loyal to Alassane Ouattara who was
president today the very bond bridge was
my territory her post below that's where
I was posted with five boys
we left the anti-riot Brigade we didn't
have any food nothing there was no
security
nothing just us we could do whatever we
wanted whatever we could
so didn't wanna tell us you know to work
force is he going to wear on fully on
boy has he gone through a prayer when
the Civil War ended he was hoping that
he would be able to join the regular
army but he didn't have a chance without
the right contact super known friend of
the family who I explained the situation
to he knew this car repair shop and
recommended me to him he's like a big
brother to me now he does everything for
me
devdi bucket a knows what Musa is going
through he lived in poverty for a long
time and wants to help him but he is
demanding and wants him to learn fast
yesterday he sent him to a customer
alone to fix a car which Musa was able
to do I never wanted to do this but now
that I'm here I'm beginning to like it
and I'm going to continue because it's
the only job I know you have to really
like it in the end
his co-workers don't know about his past
as a militiamen in Juarez forces he
hasn't told anyone about it
he knows that many people here were
supporters of ex-president bug vole
he's scared some could take revenge if
they found out that he fought for the
man who is now president every day at
lunchtime Debbie to make sure he has a
car ready and invites his friends for
lunch all right it's time for food
massage is a bit reluctant to go with
him
he's full of distrust he'd rather not
have so much to do with the others David
always encourages him to socialize
he knows that massage dream is to have a
repair shop of his own one day that's
why he wants him to be more open
there are two repair shops next to each
other so we do a lot together me
together at lunch and then we hang out
at night till 10 or 11 but the others
have gone shopping
whoosah is rather quiet after the meal
during the war he was a militiamen at a
checkpoint just near here
everything comes flooding back I love
Devaki alone the pain is still there
we're looking today it's especially hard
I swear I'll never be able to forget it
the worst thing is the guys who did it I
know them all of them I'll never forgive
them buddies people say the war's over
we're at peace now but I'm ready for
anything should not even go to prison
for it I found these on the subway
but both supporters meet up nearby among
them a number of militiamen they also
refused to accept the current situation
since the arrest of president backbone
the Ivory Coast has been held captive
watcher and France are holding us
hostage over but accounts haven't yet
been settled it's not over
we all know each other and we know who's
capable of what I'm asking I said kick
up on your wall it's closing time in the
workshop who saw bumps into a former
fighter from his unit they haven't seen
each other for years
they only chat briefly so as not to draw
attention people are already looking
over
shortly before nightfall they use a
customer's car to drive home dahveed
knows what Moosa has been through and is
aware of his potential for violence
he's letting him stay at his house to
give him a chance at a normal life the
two men share a room and even a mattress
but Musa hopes it won't be for long I
want my workshop but that requires money
you have to pay rent that's all the
tools it adds up in the evening he hooks
up with his girlfriend he's never talked
to her about his time in the militia
either her family are opposed to the
relationship and want her to marry
another man who can I swear if you hide
something from me I'll do you it I swear
by my mother if you go there I'll follow
Aditya tries to calm him down
Musa also has an important meeting
tomorrow the old friend of the family
who put him in touch with David is
coming to the workshop to see how Musa
is faring
by city
the viewers it was hard at the start
after doing other things for so long he
lost the knack for cars but it's
gradually coming back to our men who so
wants to ask whether he can get a
personal loan for his business he lets
Dovie do the talking we'll have to wait
and see I hope there won't be any more
political upheavals if more sir gets
established but it's the past behind him
and sets himself some girls then he can
make it the main thing is that he
doesn't become a soldier again if things
keep going well yes he can imagine
financing the workshop for Mossad to
support him and give me a call if
something comes out who'sa is a bit
disappointed he was hoping to get that
all-important loan sooner but those
words of encouragement are a boost he's
determined to demonstrate his car repair
talents and that his time as a
militiamen is well and truly over